italy's president has accepted the
resignation of prime minister mario
draghi after a week-long attempt to
unite his crumbling coalition failed
draghi went to sergio matarella's office
this morning to offer his resignation
for the second time in a week
the president accepted this time but
asked draghi to stay on as caretaker
until a replacement can be found
earlier in parliament draghi told
lawmakers he had tried and failed to
gain the necessary support he needed to
continue in the job
[Applause]
let's get the latest now from journalist
sima gupta in rome seema mario draghi is
highly regarded in italy and abroad he's
seen as a safe pair of hands why did he
lose the support he needs in parliament
to run the country
well essentially uh you have to remember
that when he came into this role some 17
months ago he was given this mandate to
lead a unity government a national
coalition involving the right the left
the populist so it was a really large
group of people with very differing
ideas and what we saw happen in that
vote of confidence in the upper house of
parliament in the senate on wednesday is
that the forza italia the right-wing
center-right party as well as the
far-right league party and the populist
five-star movement essentially snubbed
that vote they boycotted it all together
and so
they made their decisions for differing
reasons the five-star movement feeling
that for months their priorities were
being ignored they are pushed for things
like a basic income and a minimum salary
that they wanted to see continue uh
these things they felt among other
things were not being listened to for
forza italia and the league party the
conservative right-wing parties uh they
said uh we'll support draghi but there
has to be a shake-up of government and
we want to be in there without the
five-star movement so essentially for
differing reasons these three major uh
parties in this national coalition said
they're not gonna
partake in that vote so they just
boycotted it and that means for mr
draghi he didn't have that national
unity that he said i have the mandate to
take part so he went and made the
decision to resign to mr matarella
this collapse of the government seymour
comes as italy faces multiple crises a
severe drought an energy crunch the
prospect of a recession the timing
couldn't be worse could it
you're absolutely right terry i mean
timing everything this government's
mandate was actually supposed to run out
in the spring of 2023. so most italians
some two-thirds of them in recent polls
said that he wanted draghi to continue
to maintain the stability and there were
pleas being made from various quarters
in italy and outside as well but as you
mentioned now we're in this situation
really soaring inflation high energy
prices you've got that drought as well
with ridiculously high temperatures
the war in ukraine draghi was seen as a
safe pair of hands a respected european
leader dealing with that issue and not
to forget also about italy trying to
diversify its energy uh sources away
from russia so now you have this
situation where the center left party
leader enrique letter made it very clear
all those that did not vote in this are
responsible for the situation that
they're in right now and of course at
the european level they're wondering
about those reforms that mr draghi was
supposed to push forward in order to get
that post-pandemic recovery fund money
so what's next for draghi and the
country uh fresh elections i presume
well mr matarella has said he's taken
note of the resignation he hasn't
rejected it like what he did the day uh
six days ago but essentially he said he
took note of the resignation draghi will
remain in a caretaker role but yes
you're right it's headed towards fresh
elections uh he mr matarella has already
announced that he will be speaking to
the speakers of both houses of
parliament later this afternoon so
consultations have begun we expect that
he may dissolve parliament and call for
fresh elections as early as late
september or early october something
unheard of in italy a country normally
that approves the budget in that period
now is going or hit it towards fresh
elections
simon thank you very much for that
update journalist sima gupta there in
rome
let's get the latest from journalist
alessio perone who is joining us from
milan in italy so i mean this is
draghi's second resignation in a week
how did it get to this point
well it's difficult to say in a way and
i think we should remember our audience
that draghi was always a broad coalition
he had support from a wide range of
political parties behind him and italy
was always bound to have new elections
in spring 2023 i guess as we inched
closer to to that date uh the electoral
campaign probably started some parties
tried to make political gains that
started with a five-star movement
uh which was the biggest part of the
2018 elections and they started making
claims about ukraine about not shipping
italian weapons there
that led to more bickering than the
party splintered and then other parties
dropped out of the coalition um after
yesterday there's a real sense of
disbelief in italian media and many
wonder how much responsibility italian
political parties can be trusted with
and all of that as italy faces multiple
crises we have to mention a severe
drought an under
performing economy
in desperate need of reform the timing
couldn't be worse could it
yeah like you said and like i said the
real sense of disbelief is is partly due
to that that reason here in the north uh
in milan there's a severe drought uh
that's threatening crops um the economy
is isn't exactly thriving uh russia's
invasion in ukraine is uh another
talking point uh but more than that
italy just received a massive amount of
european money through the recovery fund
the government should decide how to
spend it and how to direct that money
and more than that if italy heads to uh
early elections as it seems likely it
will be the first time the country votes
in autumn and for reason because
the parliament should discuss the budget
in autumn and if there's no government
if there's no parliament it is going to
slow down on that front too
so what is next for draghi and the
country
well like you said earlier drug has been
asked to stay on until a caretaker can
be found um and now it's all in the
hands of president motarella um he can
decide to hold consultations with
italian political parties to see if a
new majority can be found
but political analysts are saying by far
the most likely outcome of this will be
early elicious probably in october uh
and so we're off to the races and um
yeah um i guess there might be more
surprises um a major talking point in
the electoral campaign will be migration
with the far-right parties that together
combine 40 percent of the votes in the
polls right now uh likely to make a
talking point russia will figure it
prominently in the campaign too
journalist alessio perone and milan
thank you
thank you